I lose my ability to think straight or intelligently and confrontational or
unfriendly social situations.
Any suggestions for adoptation or approvement?
Well,
a couple I suppose.
One is,
is that when you get nervous in this Hannah's situation that you're describing,
what often happens to people as they start paying attention to themselves,
they get self conscious.
So you know,
let's say I got self conscious all of a sudden during this Q and a,
what would happen is that I'd stopped paying attention to the questions and the
screen and what I'm doing and I'd start paying attention to how I was feeling
and to the nervousness.
And then I'd start to get aware that I was not responding properly and that
would make me more nervous.
And then I would get more aware of that and that can just shut me down entirely.
And that's happened to me now.
And then in a lecture and sometimes almost happened when I was talking to Sam
Harris the first time.
Um,
I,
I paused for a long time and then became aware of the pause.
And then anyways,
what you have to do in a situation like that is it's not so much that you have
to stop attending to yourself because if you start thinking I should stop
attending to myself,
then you'll just think about yourself more.
What you have to do instead is pay more attention to this situation and to the
people that you're talking to.
So you have to increase the degree to which you're at attending outwardly and
that'll stop you from attending inwardly.
Um,
that's very effective technique.
You can practice that.
Generally speaking,
every time you get nervous,
start paying more attention and that'll,
that'll,
that'll help you out a lot.
Um,
the,
the really good suggestion for social anxiety in general is that if you see most
people,
but not everyone,
but most people have enough implicit social skill because they were reasonably
socialized when they were children so that they do know how to act in social
situations,
but they get anxious and then that interferes with them implementing what they
know.
Just like if you're a pianist and you get anxious and self conscious while
you're playing,
you'll forget what you know.
Because while you've activated a different part of your brain,
if you can remember to pay attention and you can direct your attention outward
and you attend hard enough,
then what will happen?
And try to put the other person at ease and try to ask them questions,
then that'll kick in the automatic because you're paying attention to what the
person is doing and to their facial expressions and all of that,
that will clue in the automatic and implicit,
uh,
knowledge that you have and make things much more smooth and,
and,
uh,
and anxiety free.
So attention really attention really plays a huge role in regulating anxiety.